This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Okay, this is Secret Stairs East Bay walk number 30. If there is ever a place that's higher up than where you're standing, there's a reasonable chance you're gonna want to go up. And wherever there is sufficient demand to move between two points of different elevation, there are stairs. Turn left, walking between the imposing gates onto Rock Ridge Boulevard. Yep. Note the line of very tall, very old palm trees ahead of you.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。好的，这是“东湾秘密阶梯”第30号步行路线。如果某个地方比你站立的地方更高，你很有可能会想走上去。只要有足够的需求在两个不同海拔的点之间移动，就会有楼梯。向左转，穿过雄伟的大门走上罗克里奇大道。是的。注意你前方那排非常高、非常古老的棕榈树。
Check. California has a lot of hills. And in certain neighborhoods in our great state, you can find outdoor stairs. Then just past the house at 6095, find the almost hidden staircase. It is your first climb. Public stairs. Let's see. 6095, 609, 6107, 6101. If you know how to look for them. Holy moly, I totally miss this. Wow, I walked right by these steps and there they are. That's our producer Sam Greenspan and as you may remember, he just moved
好的。加利福尼亚州有很多山丘。在我们这个伟大的州的某些街区，你可以找到户外的楼梯。然后走到6095号房屋后面，找到那条几乎隐藏的楼梯。这是你的第一段攀爬。公共楼梯。让我想想。6095、609、6107、6101。如果你知道怎么寻找它们的话。天哪，我完全错过这个了。哇，我从这些台阶旁边直接走过去，而它们就在那里。那是我们的制作人山姆·格林斯潘，你可能还记得，他刚刚搬到
to the Bay Area. I think I knew California had hills, I just didn't realize how much of a thing it is here. The large number of often hidden public staircases is one of the major reasons why the Bay Area is so great. The tourist crippling Philbert steps to Cointour are not to be missed, the monument-waste staircase that leads you to my favorite place in the city the pedestal of what used to be sutros triumph of light and liberty statue oh and I go out of my way every single day to walk the two blocks worth of stairs by my new place in the Berkeley Hills We have public staircases and they rock and the guy who wrote the book on East Bay Public Stairs is Charles Fleming.
湾区。我想我知道加州有山丘，只是我没意识到这里的山丘有这么大的影响力。数量庞大且往往隐藏着的公共楼梯，是湾区如此伟大的主要原因之一。通往库因图尔的、让游客双腿发软的菲尔伯特台阶绝对不容错过；那座通往我城中最爱之地的纪念碑式废弃楼梯——苏特罗光明与自由胜利雕像的底座——哦，我每天都会特意绕道去走走伯克利山我新住处旁边的两街区长的楼梯。我们有公共楼梯，而且它们酷毙了。写了一本关于东湾公共楼梯的书的那个人叫查尔斯·弗莱明。
But he's not from here. The East Bay stair book is actually a spin-off of his previous book, Secret Stairs of Los Angeles, which is where Charles lives. And that's where Sam tracked him down. My name is Charles Fleming. I'm the author of Secret Stairs, a walking guide to the historic staircases of Los Angeles. There's more than 30 people assembled here because one Sunday a month for the past few
但他不是本地人。东湾阶梯那本书其实是他上一本书《洛杉矶秘密阶梯》的衍生作品，查尔斯就住在那里。这也是山姆追踪找到他的地方。我叫查尔斯·弗莱明。我是《洛杉矶秘密阶梯：洛杉矶历史阶梯步行指南》的作者。这里聚集了30多人，因为在过去的几年里，每个月的一个星期天，
years, Charles has been leading public tours through the routes in his Secret Stairs Book. And we're here where Sunset Boulevard meets the Pacific Coast Highway in Pacific Palisades about to embark on a stair walk. It's actually stair walk number 41 from the book secret stairs and we will set forth here, walk up the coast highway a little bit and then enter the historic Castile Maure area of the Pacific Palisades, which features a number of striking public staircases. And we're off. Back before the tour is before the book, before we really cared about public staircases at all, Charles just needed to walk.
查尔斯一直都在带领公众参观他的《秘密阶梯》书中的路线。我们现在来到了日落大道与太平洋海岸公路交汇处的太平洋帕利塞德，即将开始一场阶梯徒步。这实际上是《秘密阶梯》书中的第41号阶梯徒步路线，我们将从这里出发，沿着海岸公路走一小段，然后进入太平洋帕利塞德的历史悠久的卡斯蒂利亚莫雷地区，那里有许多引人注目的公共阶梯。我们出发吧。在这次徒步之前，在出版这本书之前，在我们真正关心公共阶梯之前，查尔斯只是需要散步。
Yeah, I got started with the stairs because I was trying to walk my way out of a surgery. I had had two hip replacements and two spinal surgeries in the space of about six years. And I was up for a third spinal surgery and I simply couldn't trace it. I knew what the surgery was going to be like and I knew what the rehab was going to be like. So I told the surgeon I'm not coming because I had found a little bit of walking relieved the pain that I was in. So I started walking flat streets, maybe two blocks at a time. It was that hard to walk. Oh, it was, literally, I would have to have my wife put me
是的，我开始走楼梯是因为我试图通过散步来摆脱一次手术。在大约六年的时间里，我做过两次髋关节置换手术和两次脊柱手术。我还面临着第三次脊柱手术，而我简直无法想象。我知道那会是怎样的一场手术，我也知道康复过程会是怎样的。所以我告诉外科医生我不去了，因为我发现稍微走走路能减轻我感到的疼痛。于是我开始走平坦的街道，一次可能走两个街区。走路就是这么艰难。哦，确实如此，字面意思上，我得让我妻子把我
in the car and drive me to a flat street and help me out of the car and watch me walk two blocks, pick me up and take me home. That was the first day. And you know, within a week, I was walking three blocks and within a month, I was walking a half a mile. And because it was working, I kept going. And when I got boardwalking the flats, I started walking the hills. When I got boardwalking the hills, I started checking out the staircases. So first point of historic interest here.
扶进车里，开车带我去一条平街，帮我下车，看着我走两个街区，然后接我回家。那是第一天。你知道的，一周之内，我就能走三个街区了；一个月之内，我能走半英里。因为这管用，所以我就坚持了下来。当我走腻了平路时，我开始爬山。当我爬腻了山时，我开始探索楼梯。所以这里的第一个历史名胜是。
Charles knew a little about the staircases. He had seen them around silver lake where he lives. The staircases are generally either from the 1920s boom years or from the days of the Works Progress Administration. They were built because developers in hilly areas needed to find a way for prospective home buyers to get down from their houses to school or a church or a street car line. But the depression and then World War II halted staircase construction. And after that the car really became the dominant feature of the Los Angeles landscape. So staircases weren't necessary because they weren't trying to serve a pedestrian population anymore. They were trying to serve a car population. So they stopped building
查尔斯对这些阶梯略知一二。他经常在他居住的银湖附近看到它们。这些阶梯通常要么来自20世纪20年代的经济繁荣时期，要么来自公共事业振兴署的时期。建造它们是因为山区的开发商需要想办法让潜在的购房者从他们的房子走到学校、教堂或有轨电车线路。但大萧条和随后的第二次世界大战暂停了阶梯的建设。在那之后，汽车真正成为了洛杉矶景观的主导特征。因此，阶梯不再必要了，因为它们不再试图服务于步行人口，而是试图服务于汽车人口。所以他们停止了建造
the staircases. Charles looked for an inventory of all the public staircases in the city, but he couldn't find one. So I decided I would map. I figured they were probably 15 of them and I would make that my little quest. Turned out that his neighborhood, Silver Lake, had about 50 public staircases. And uh, but I felt so much healthier when I was done with that, that I decided I would do Echo Park too. I figured there were probably 10 and 12 of them over there. We'll turn out there were about 60 in Echo Park.
阶梯。查尔斯寻找城市中所有公共阶梯的清单，但他找不到。于是我决定自己绘制地图。我想大概有15个吧，我打算把这当作我的小任务。结果发现他所在的街区——银湖——大约有50个公共阶梯。而且，嗯，当我完成这些时，我感觉健康多了，所以我决定也把回声公园走一遍。我想那里大概有10到12个。结果证明回声公园大约有60个。
But I felt so healthy when I finished that that I just decided to continue. So Charles kept extending his reach to different parts of Los Angeles. Pacific palisades where we are now. And he kept walking Santa Monica, Hollywood, Los Felix, and walking Franklin Hills, and now Washington Highland Park, Eagle Rock, Garbons,
但当我完成时，我感觉太健康了，于是我决定继续下去。因此查尔斯不断将他的范围扩大到洛杉矶的不同地区。我们现在所在的太平洋帕利塞德。他继续走圣莫尼卡、好莱坞、洛斯费利兹，走富兰克林山，现在是华盛顿高地公园、鹰岩、加尔本斯，
and the Valley, and Pasadena. By the end of it, he had recorded routes that use 400 public staircases. 400 in change. Well, over 500 that I actually mapped, but in terms of ones that I was able to turn into practical walks, 400 and something.
还有山谷和帕萨迪纳。到最后，他记录下了使用400个公共阶梯的路线。400多个。实际上我绘制了地图的有500多个，但就那些我能将其转化为实际步行路线的而言，有400多个。
Mapping the stairs and making all the routes to connect them took Charles more than three years. At first, he just wandered aimlessly through the neighborhoods, but over time, his approach began to get a little more sophisticated. Often it was just looking for hilly areas where street cars used to run. And then I gradually figured out that if you found
绘制阶梯地图并制作连接它们的各种路线花了他三年多的时间。起初，他在街区里漫无目的地闲逛，但随着时间推移，他的方法开始变得稍微复杂一些。通常只是寻找有轨电车以前开过的多山地区。然后我逐渐发现，如果你找到
a curvy street, a lamp post, and a sewer line, and a fire hydrant, in the middle of a curve, there was probably gonna be a public staircase. Because if a city is going to retain ownership of a little slice of land, it's probably going to want to pack it with as many public utilities as possible. These little slices of land often snake between houses and yards, and that's one of the great things about them.
一条弯曲的街道、一根路灯杆、一条下水道管线和一个位于弯道中间的消防栓，那附近可能就会有一个公共阶梯。因为如果一个城市要保留一小块土地的所有权，它可能会希望尽可能多地塞满公共公用设施。这些小块土地经常在房屋和庭院之间像蛇一样蜿蜒穿梭，这也是它们的伟大之处之一。
It's exploring, getting really close to someone's yard and house without actually trespassing. But not everyone loves that these stairs are public. Once that a stairs we came across was fenced off. I'm not sure who put the gate up there. It's another public staircase that was open to the public until quite recently. Charles says that at night, sometimes the staircases can get used by people looking for a hidden place to do shady business. I suppose it's possible that could happen up here in the Pacific Palisades,
这就是探索，在不真正擅自闯入的情况下，非常靠近别人的院子和房屋。但并不是所有人都喜欢这些阶梯是公共的。有一次，我们遇到的一段阶梯被栅栏围起来了。我不确定是谁把门装在那里的。这是另一个直到最近才向公众开放的公共阶梯。查尔斯说，到了晚上，这些阶梯有时会被那些寻找隐蔽地方进行非法勾当的人使用。我想在太平洋帕利塞德这里确实可能会发生这种情况，
but what seems more likely, at least in this case, is that someone fenced off the stairway to keep out the riffraff. The staircases all go through residential districts, and because they go quite narrowly between homes, there are a number of staircases around the city that have been closed by the residents against other residents without any permission from the city. Can they do that? Well, they can't do it legally. Charles has managed to get some of these fences taken down by leaning on congressmen and city officials, though some use less bureaucratic methods.
但看起来更有可能的是，至少在这个案例中，有人用栅栏围住了楼梯，把无赖挡在外面。这些阶梯都穿过住宅区，而且由于它们在房屋之间穿行得相当狭窄，城市周围有许多阶梯被居民在未经城市任何许可的情况下封闭起来以防范其他居民。他们能那样做吗？好吧，他们不能合法地这样做。查尔斯通过向国会议员和城市官员施压，设法拆除了一些这样的栅栏，尽管有些人使用的方法不那么官僚。
I know one fellow who just goes around with a bolt cutter and liberates the stairs. We couldn't confirm this, but I just love the thought of a guy going around in the dead of night with a pair of bolt cutters, liberating staircases. This is my kind of vigilante. The idea of public access to the small spaces in between private property is in and of itself compelling as is the lure of hidden passageways connecting neighborhoods across the city. But part of the magic of public stairways is that you just don't see public construction devoted solely to pedestrians all that much anymore. They feel like going back in time when your
我认识一个家伙，他带着一把螺栓剪到处跑，解放了这些楼梯。我们无法证实这一点，但我就是喜欢一个男人在深夜拿着一把螺栓剪四处游荡、解放阶梯的想法。这就是我喜欢的那种义警。公众对私人财产之间狭小空间享有通行权的这种想法本身就很吸引人，正如连接全城各个社区的隐蔽通道的诱惑一样。但公共阶梯的魅力部分在于，你再也看不到多少专门供行人使用的公共建设了。它们感觉就像是回到了过去，那时你的
feet connected you to everything around you. LA is kind of a hard city to own. I don't think people feel an intimate personal connection to it the way that they might if they grew up in Boston or London. And I think part of that is that you're in a car going past it so fast that most of the city is just the name of an off ramp. It's not you don't have any sense of who lives there or why they live there or what it would be like. And when you slow down and move at pedestrian pace it gives you the opportunity to get
双脚将你与周围的一切紧密相连。洛杉矶是一个很难让人真正拥有的城市。我不认为人们对它有一种亲密的个人联系，就像他们在波士顿或伦敦长大时可能会有的那种联系。我想部分原因在于你坐在车里飞驰而过，以至于城市的大部分都只是一个出口匝道的名字。你对谁住在那里、他们为什么住在那里、或者那会是怎样的生活毫无概念。当你放慢脚步，以行人的速度移动时，它会给你提供一个机会去
a little more connected to it. I think anybody would want that. I think as human beings that's part of why we live in cities, why we live in communities. If the streets are arteries, then the public walkways are the occasional capillaries. They can get so narrow that only one red blood cell can fit at a time. And when you encounter someone on the path you're forced to interact to step to the side, maybe smile or not. Also, it really feels like your trespassing. I can't stress enough how fun that is. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sam Green, Span, and me Roman Mars thanks to a Lana Gold state for taking pictures for us.
与它建立更紧密的联系。我想任何人都想要这样。我认为作为人类，这就是为什么我们生活在城市里，为什么我们生活在社区里。如果街道是动脉，那么人行道就是偶尔出现的毛细血管。它们可以窄到一次只能容纳一个红血球通过。当你在小路上遇到某人时，你被迫进行互动：侧身让路，也许微笑，或者不笑。另外，这真的感觉像你在擅自闯入。我怎么强调这有多好玩都不为过。“99%隐形”本周由山姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。感谢阿拉娜·戈尔德斯坦为我们拍照。
We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, KALW and San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, boevelings to Secret Star walks, and you can always tell us about your favorite hidden stairs, or the flatlander equivalent of hidden stairs, at 99%invisible.org. and stairs at 99%invisible.org. Radio Tepio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。我在推特上的账号是罗曼·马尔斯，探索秘密阶梯，你随时可以在99%invisible.org上告诉我们你最喜欢的隐藏阶梯，或者隐藏阶梯的平原版本。还有99%invisible.org上的阶梯。来自PRX的Radio Tepio。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。